foreign
dangerous what's happening right now
there's no way that we're tracking all
these people that are crossing the
border
the amount of people is overwhelming to
see when you see 150 people standing
there 200 people standing down there and
wow what about the ones that don't want
to get caught Now's the Time to come
the whole world is crossing the border
and these are the people that want to
get caught there's a lot of people that
don't want to get caught and where are
they going and who's supporting them and
that's what's scary
we don't know who's Crossing and so we
do have we have workers out here and
there has been times where they've tried
to blend in with the workers and it's
it's pretty scary like Trump we have you
know we have work we have buses that
transport people to the fields and they
try to mix in with the groups
it's not it's it's not something that I
look at like oh my gosh this is scary
for the Yuma Community it's more about
the the nation as a whole
you have a lot of people that live in
San Luis Mexico that come across every
single day and they don't like this
either because all those people go to
their town
before they cross and the crime rates in
these towns have skyrocketed because the
cartel has taken over the cartels are
warring in San Luis they've had over a
hundred assassinations in the last year
um vying for control of that area
terrorizing those streets and that's 15
miles from here and speaking with law
enforcement on both sides of the Border
especially the Liaisons they've
confirmed that the majority of these
hits have been people who have been
involved in the trafficking
when I was young they used to people
used to come across but they were
actually people that were willing to
come to work and do
be productive and I'm sure there was
some bad people that
you know you hear the stat of the it's
only 10 of the people are bad well you
got five million people that just came
across and now you have 500 000
criminals that came across at a minimum
that's
four times the size of Yuma
you have all these cartels and bread and
basically run this border
funneling people and drugs across and
it's big money 10 people
to be aware from eight thousand dollars
a person up to forty thousand dollars a
person and that just depends on where
you come from
they know these people are have cash to
get here
just to get there to say I'm crossing
you have to pay somebody it doesn't just
happen for free
these people come across they're still
indebted to the cartel not everybody is
able to pay for it and they come as
indentured servants and they live below
the system the border the border is 100
not secure it's wide open there's a lot
of people that don't like the United
States for whatever reason there's
plenty of people that want to get in
here and do some damage like it's like
ticking Time Bomb I'm sure it might be
too late because people this has been
like this for two and a half years
it's not a political discussion this is
National Security this is human
trafficking this is the trafficking of
Narcotics that are killing Americans
unless this situation changes and we
Take Back Control from the cartels for
the trafficking coming across our border
it will only get worse